i'm a slytherin here so we gotta talk
about um draco talk
i'm not mr tech savvy really but a
friend of mine
got me on and sort of showed me the
ropes she showed me how to
how to how to tic toc and then it sort
of taken a life of its own now but i'm
having so much fun with it because
if you go to the hashtag draco talk you
see all of these like collaborative
videos you know we're no longer are we
just retweeting or commenting
they're actually taking things that i've
done and then putting their own
spin on it and then i can see that and
put my own spin on their stuff
it's turning into a whole monster of its
own um but i'm really really enjoying it
so yeah i'm gonna keep the uh keep the
draco talkers
uh happy for as long as i can it's so
good like i
i have to imagine rico always had his
own like fans but what has it been like
going from like
the villain of the franchise to maybe
like the most thirsted after at this
point
interesting choices um eligible bachelor
of the franchise well
i will happily uh swoon um at the kind
kind words uh i just think it's awesome
that you know
if a character that wasn't um
particularly the most popular
um he's now turning into a life of his
own uh
yeah he's great he's got so many layers
he's misunderstood he's also a bit of a
get
um he's uh he doesn't know how he needs
a hug really i think maybe
maybe people feel sorry for him it just
needs a bit of affection
um either way i'm highly flattered and
i intend to uh do my best to satisfy
that
uh desire it is highly entertaining have
you been keeping in touch with the uh
the hp
cast during quarantine yeah yeah i have
actually i think i'd probably
ironically to my character um i'd
probably keep in touch with them
more than the rest of them do it to be
fair i saw the uh weasley twins the
other day we went up played some golf um
always chatting with uh um a lot of the
other
guys on whatsapp and and staying in
touch with emma and making sure
everything's all right and yeah
it's it's been nice because you know
it's the 19th year anniversary of
november 14th
so i'm planning some sort of digital
celebration on this beach.com website
so i'm trying to wrangle all the uh all
the oldies back together again for um
well to celebrate the uh to celebrate
the achievement really
release our new friends upon the world
now
we've rehearsed this for six months it
took me a hot minute to process that
this was this was you in the movie
what was your reaction to seeing your
final look for the first time
final look was great we had there was
some severe camera testing for this um
for all sorts of different reasons for
prosthetics for eyes for
hair etc um and i just had to have so
much fun doing it really they kind of
gave me
um quite a lot of creative license to
sort of go as crazy as i want to and as
soon as i started getting trinkets tied
in my hair
and bags of children's teeth attached to
my belt i was uh
i was loving it and it was impossible to
be tom really when you're in all that
outfit there's no walking around
everyone's you know you're sort of
sauntering everywhere and dancing and
sort of
um gliding around the set so it was a
lot of fun
yeah so um children's teeth elaborate on
that
yes well you know you don't get to see
it to be fair this is these are the
props that i
gave myself really i gave myself and i
painted my own nails some sort of
translucent
green color and all these different
things that were hanging off my
off my belt there was an incredible
amount of attention to detail so that
was uh that's all i'm sort of
highlighting really
i'm noticing uh like i feel like you
want me to notice your mask your elbow
mask here
yeah my purpose like yeah i am really
it's a gryffindor one i'm giving them
away as part of a
heroes wear masks villains wear them
better thing
but yes i know terrible choice my bad
basically they
they they gave me some free masks and
they gave me more they they gave me more
gryffindor ones and they did slytherin
buggers those are cool now i'm stuck
with it but yes either way
either way it's cool so i feel like
you've really leaned into the
your roles of uh scaring kids which i
love what's your
what's your favorite thing about playing
a villainous role
just being someone so different from
myself really i think i wouldn't be very
good at playing myself at all
and these guys you know yeah they they
seem villainous compared to the other
characters but they don't think
that that villainous they're just doing
everything that they want to do
uh i think it's right you know he takes
such a joy in being the
master of menace and the uh the newbie
of nightmares et cetera
he has such such fun doing it that
it's fun for me to play it i suppose and
the further they are
are away from tom the muggle the better
really um
so i think i just gotta get the chance
to let go and be a bit of a nutter
so uh and and yes i suppose
when it comes to scaring the kids that
was really down to the uh the fabulous
hair makeup team and the wardrobe and
the
and so forth because yeah i was just
having a i was i was i felt like a rock
star
a demon rock star just sauntering around
so that was a lot of fun for me
that's a good explanation i read that
you were kind of inspired by mick jagger
is that accurate
there's a bunch of inspirations i don't
think we ever actually nailed one down
but
it was definitely about the way he moved
that was a bit mick jaggery because
there's
there's a couple of little dance bits in
there and little
little ways of yeah he's very he's quite
feminine actually uh
even though being this this this
terrible terrible um
creature i think it all sort of
blended into one really a bit of this
bit of that bit of this and
uh yeah that's the uh that's how we came
up with the with the gg